up everybody if you use your imagination
and almost sounds like the real Game of
Thrones theme music because it's so
iconic but what a budget we're in a beer
budget and we have champagne tastes but
we're back back this is it this is part
three of the poster design challenge
welcome everybody to the Academy site of
the future today I'm joined as always by
Matthew and Jonah everybody let's get
through this we have to eat lunch so
this is going to drive the pace of this
final episode Oh a second - final
episode I suppose this is the official
game of Thrones design challenge this is
part 3 in the three-part challenge right
you guys were tasked with designing a
minimalist poster thematically linked to
the house of your choice and Matthews
clearly laid out two three criteria one
concept - composition and three
integration of the sigil and the word
mark remember you're supposed to pick a
house of your choice one of the great
houses of Westeros and then you're going
to design a poster around this so let's
take a look at your work let's just jump
right into it okay
Matthew you ready to go yeah I just want
to make sure we're we're live we're live
I think we're live
Matty who has his ninja mask on it's
because he's the unsullied man okay I
just want to say this at the top of the
show if you have not seen seasons
what season eight season eight season
eight six the final episode you may want
to stop right now I'm not gonna do any
spoilers but I can't control what people
submit and there are some spoilers
within the posters I think and if you
don't read into it too much you'll be
okay so I hope you're sticking around
because we're gonna critique these
posters a bunch of you submitted posters
and we're gonna review a few of them and
then we're gonna tell you the top five
posters that Matthew and I picked to
Vance on to the final to see who wins
the ultimate prize when you play the
game of Thrones either win or we lied
yeah good night we are good let's just
jump in here we go here's the first
entry who is this is for a house orange
can you read this is a Colima KO it
okay good eyes they're good idolize
Aaron I believe Aaron and they have a
falcon and there's the moon door and all
that kind of stuff let's talk about
what's working about this I like that
it's very minimal it's high contrast
it's graphically just very interesting
they've got this Scarface split screen
going on mm-hmm that there's a blast out
of the white side and the kind of
yin-yang thing going
I like those parts of it what I don't
like about it is that when you have this
kind of composition every time you have
typography it has to do that kind of
reverse negative thing and I just think
that's not a great way to resolve how to
integrate your typography but when I'm
thinking about conceptually like what
does this tell me so a concept isn't
that you have an idea to do something
because that's just intent that's not an
idea a concept to me is when a plus B
equals C that it's a riddle for the
viewer to kind of unpackage and solve
and then there's a little bit delight at
the end so it has to have an element of
surprise if you think about the Amazon
logo it looks like a little smile and
most people get that but when you also
see the placement of that little smile
it's from A to Z Amazon so they sell
everything from A to Z you get that
little bit of delight same thing with a
FedEx logo when you discover there's a
white arrow hidden between some of the
letters between the E and the X of FedEx
that's a little bit of delight and
that's what we're talking about when we
say conceptually that's what we're
looking for okay so conceptually this is
fairly flat it's a good graphic
execution I don't love the typography
that it's centered and it's just split
in half like that it's not really
telling me and if he knew as far as I'm
concerned this could just be a simple
logo just scaled up mm-hmm so that's one
of the reasons why I don't love it
your thoughts yeah just the only things
I would add to this is that with duality
where you break the frame in half it
would be nice if there's like you said
Chris if there's something conceptual
where you have something on one side and
then maybe something revealed on the
other side like if there's a play on the
negative and positive space right now
there's not much of that going on so I
fortunately that's a miss opportunity
the second part is because the black and
white
lines up on the middle are there it's
very hard to read that hard now so it
creates some weird visual friction
they're right in the middle of the frame
there so yeah those are two things that
are problems with this let me tell you
how you might want to use the split
screen black and white contrasting thing
if you're trying to show that the person
has two sides of them like Matthew
mentioned duality like there's a split
personality there's a good side the
public facing thing and then there's the
negative side so a great example would
be a politician who appears to be a
licker with a good person helping out
with charities maybe they're doing a
ribbon-cutting ceremony and then on the
other side they're like burying bodies
in the backyard because they're mobsters
and that's how you use that duality
concept okay so let's keep moving on
okay next up I can't read this cuz my
eyesight's going this is Lillian
Figueroa yeah Lillian Figueroa living in
Figueroa this is a really nice image
here let's just take a moment to take a
look at it
unfortunately because you use a very
light creamy color background that when
you use our template we can't it's hard
for us to make out the edges so you guys
just kind of stare at the screen and
kind of visualize that there is an edge
to it okay so this is for a house
baratheon mm-hmm they have the the house
Montague yeah ours is the fury and they
have the stag it's a good drawing and
inside of it what is that the person
with the axe is that the guy with a
hammer
cuz he's Baratheon you know I don't I
don't know actually I don't know who
what is that the character is it looked
like it's just a soldier with with horns
on him okay I was hoping that it would
be I forget the dude's name now the
bastard son oh oh right
he's Baratheon right the last Baratheon
yeah shoot well some guys that really
smart will tell us what that is
let's talk about what's good about this
I love that there's this large
silhouette that draws my eye in and I
think you're doing this thing where the
eye also lines up with the moon and the
scene and there's a really cool battle
scene that's going on and you can see
that there's a moment of tension and the
axis being kind of brought back and it's
gonna be released and I like that mm-hmm
and then there
the sigil that you design and the logo
type from the previous two challenges so
I like that it's a good kind of design
integration it's working for me mm-hmm I
like that the the eye is the moon in the
clouds there that was a nice little
touch so right above the axe there's a
moon there which is parting from the
clouds it's also the eye of the stag I
thought that's well lined up so it's one
of these nice kind of like a double
exposure image where these two things
are lined up so that's that's really
nice and people are confirming in the
chat that this is supposedly Robert
Baratheon
it's Robert Baratheon yeah okay how do
we know that Roberts a big dude yeah I'm
not sure people say hammer and helmet
are his hammer and helmet okay
great cool so I like that thank you very
smart internet our YouTube fans our
audience they're very up to speed with
this kind of stuff so thank you for
filling in the knowledge gaps there man
tonight more fans but we're not that
hardcore like we love the show but we
don't know every little bit as
apparently it's very apparent because we
can't recall the names so Robert
Baratheon that's him it must be an
important battle scene I guess I would
like a little more clues as to what's
going on so that I can get the secondary
and tertiary read as you dive deeper you
discover more things Stefan Bucher was
on our show he talked about how you want
to build an Easter egg so when you dive
in deeper and deeper you see more and
more mm-hm and that's that's a very
great way to reward the viewer by
spending more time looking at your image
mm-hmm right yeah I want to say even the
hierarchies pretty nice on this because
you have the Baratheon at the bottom of
the frame that's standing out and then
you have the stag that's reading as a
big silhouette so if you squint your
eyes that's probably one of the first
things you read and then as you kind of
go back into the frame you have the
character Robert Baratheon and the
mid-ground with the black and then more
and more steps behind that so I just
want to say that the depth of this frame
is really nice and there's a good use of
contrast coming all the way foreground
going all the way back well done well
done let's move on to the next one okay
and you guys that are watching your show
feel free to comment as we go so we know
how you feel about it let us know if you
like it what suggestions you might have
if you disagree or agree with us just
let us know we can read the comments as
you're as we're going
here okay next up this is oh my gosh
ja ja vroom ridden a Rodney Rodney I
don't know the first sounds like a
Brazilian like Portuguese name mmm Jeff
room like Rossi oh I don't know okay
Game of Thrones is for a house Aaron the
moon door as high as honor it's got a
lot of components to it pretty
interesting poster we can see that
they've rebuilt the moon door
which is an integral part of their
castle mm-hmm right and then they have
the house sigil right in the center I'm
looking for another story element in
here or the elements of surprise mm-hmm
and let me let me explain what I mean by
that so let's dive in here onto my iPad
okay let's switch over to the iPad now
you guys can see that can we move the
mic a little bit so I I think here let
me get this I think this is replicating
this shape and it's not adding a whole
lot to it so I think the way to go was
to bring the sigil down here maybe so
that it's part of the poster but it's
not the whole thing okay so let me undo
all that so you guys can see what's
going on the next thing that I would
suggest possibly doing in terms of
double images the moon door is really
scary when the doors open to show what's
underneath like it's really far away
what happens here okay yes I would
suggest that but another way to do this
I don't know what the meaning of it but
this would be your second kind of
secondary read on it which is what if
this weren't I hmm
cuz they're so high up they were kind of
watching what's going on and we don't
know who the eye is maybe it's the
person who murders the the king it could
be from oh I don't know what a sneaky
character in the show I can't say who
that might be you know but we're looking
for an additional idea or a component
that makes it greater than the sum of
the parts that's what we were really
talking about when we talk about adding
an idea to it okay all right yeah
anything you want to add no I think
there's I would say yeah that's the
central element there so we want to make
the most of that
that area yeah you could even have
somebody kind of like falling back and
that would have already been a little
bit more interest so that would be dope
suggestion there Matt I don't have the
ability to scrub this part out and do
that but what Matthew's talking about is
this I'll draw it on the side let me
switch colors here so if it were a
person like this falling backwards in
space let me just try to show you the
lack of illustration skills that I may
or may not have right right so we draw
somebody like that inside the moon door
mm-hmm and if you could imagine the moon
door being much much bigger mm-hmm I
don't know if the is it a round opening
at the bottom of the moon door is it a
square I don't recall off the top okay
let's just do circle right now so we
have that and then you can indicate
falling by little clues right something
like that so it's a very centered
perspective and then you can crop into
the poster it and do a little bit of the
brickwork mmm the masonry work outside
oh I think that would pretty dope it
kind of feels a little like
double-oh-seven yeah I so that's that
could work Matthew great suggestion on
your part there that's why you creative
director here so I didn't get any the
big books that's why that's why he has
to think on the fly job okay so that's a
suggestion there that would be pretty
cool you know what I might even add is
like this a hand or somebody looking
know just like a force perspective of a
person then you're looking down mm-hmm
it's like what happened we don't know
and I'd keep it silhouetted so that we
don't know the whole story right I love
that there that's an alley-oop so what I
would do is if I could draw this again I
would scale the guy down much much
smaller right then down done with me
below it's like a little river or
something we don't know right now that
has a lot of depth and power right
that's their famous thing the moon door
okay yeah and you can even have a broach
or something on the shoulder of somebody
that has decidua that you've designed to
integrate it in there that's a little
Easter egg house Aaron as high as honor
look how much tension is created now
yeah very very in poverty
Petre Fitri and the chat is saying
something like the Vertigo posted by
saul bass yeah yeah yes that's right
very powerful yeah so do it in the same
style that you're doing the color
palettes look it looks good and we know
you know how to illustrate and make
really interesting things just we're
missing the story component what's the
narrative aspect of this mm-hm and I
think that could be really cool okay
let's move on let's move on next up
let's see who this is this is Fabien
croats sir okay Fabien is doing for
House Targaryen I'm gonna have to guess
because there's no house daguerreian on
this poster yeah that's the first
immediate problem the second problem I
see is that you've simplified the sigil
from the house I've not seen this in one
of the entries or maybe I haven't I
forgot about it but it pretty closely
resembles the existing sigil for the
house so in terms of like if this were
just standalone I like the sigil quite a
lot but in reference to what kind of
departure or what kind of unique take
you you have made on the original logo
it's more of a modification as opposed
to an original illustration so I have
issues with that and we're really
missing a story element and also the
house logo type the word mark and the
sigil unless that's the sigil that
you've designed so really we didn't want
the poster challenge to be just you
taking the sigil and blowing it up and
adding texture to it mm-hmm
because then we would have made a poster
challenge to begin with mm-hmm okay you
know the Leos Valyria also points out
that it's really really no no Valyria
Flores okay or maybe I'm not rolling the
R's enough but it's it's red on black
too so the contrast there is very hard
to read it is in this display you just
need it up the luminance because red on
black does work it does read you just
need to control the luminous so the
black needs to be blacker and the red
needs to be a little bit more chroma and
luminance right that's it it's tricky it
is a little tricky
it is kind of low contrast for us mm-hmm
speaking of low contrast let's look at
the next one no hole this is from Adam
Harris Adam Harris this one's kind of
hard to see kind of like the longest
night huh
if you're gonna give me a hard time
about this squint episode as we call it
as you can see nothing everything's
black and inky my OLED TV was fine man I
saw all the depth yeah but we'll talk
about that later
let's not together okay no that's all
right that's right so again I think this
is for House Targaryen I believe that's
a dragon and you can see a little bit of
detail on the dragon's face my
suggestion here is I like the way that
you lit up the eyes and we can really
spot the eyes but having a little bit of
that yellow and orange the burnt umber
kind of catching one edge of the face or
rim light this dragon or something so
that we can see a little bit more I'm
not saying you have to turn on all the
lights in the room to show the dragon
but just give me a little bit more okay
the other thing I'm not getting from
this is what's the action what's the
dramatic question that's being asked and
I was asking myself that in the season
finale
what were the dramatic questions being
asked and the answers there weren't any
sadly season finale oh my god series
finale okay so the dragon is there House
Targaryen we're missing that we're
missing your sigil we're missing lots of
things here I do like the illustration I
wish you were lit a little bit more and
it did something maybe it could be oh
let's try let's try let's get back on
the pad here what if we had one of the
hooks one of the hooks what the heck
it's not allowing me to draw now let me
go back out let me hit play here and see
if I can draw again what if we had no I
know why it's user error the hook of the
claw right and something was on here
maybe it's a drop of blood or it's a
banner of a house tattered a little bit
so you can't totally tell what's going
on but that there's a little story
element to it Matthew I'm not really
seeing much of the dragon in here so I'm
gonna just highlight so people can see
mm-hmm okay Matthew you have any
thoughts on that yeah I would love it I
love the idea that there's a foreground
element it'd be cool if it was a person
like the next victim that's about to get
burned in the foreground it could be
it could be the silhouette of a person
and then maybe we could even open the
mouth of the Dragon we're similar to how
we've done with the eyes where that's a
very bright focal point you can have the
brightness of the flames possibly coming
from the mouth to also accentuate the
the details that are there so you have
some some source of lighting there to
illuminate the scene and then you could
even put something in the foreground
like a character that's about to get
burned okay we could do that so we can
fill this part in right trying to do
this with iPad here yeah and do note
that's pretty good yeah I'm trying try
you know hey not too bad and then
there's a silhouette here right it's
something we don't know it could be a
battle pose like this could be the
golden golden company oh right yeah hard
to see here guys I'm sorry I apologize
just trying to sketch it out so you guys
can see so in the foreground we can see
something happening but we're not quite
sure what it is just yet mm-hmm like
will they what I want to make sure is
that we don't just tell the whole story
that we're hinting at it we're teasing
at a scene or a moment something that's
really important that only after
completing the story in the series do
you realize the meaning of the poster
you don't want to tell the whole thing
because then there's no point of
watching it doesn't become a teaser
anymore and you may get into some
trouble with the show producers the show
runners here's another thing that we can
do what if we took the I made it really
big Matthew yeah that's cool okay so
then we're gonna crop into it like mmm
okay let's crop into it and then
whatever the details of of the dragon
are and the reason why I'm not drawing
the details like what if instead of that
slit it was the seam the reflection the
reflection of something that's going on
I like that right we could do that and
then this could be smoke smoldering some
cool things coming out maybe you can do
something like that mm-hmm
that's what we're looking for guys
that's what we mean when we say a
concept an image within the image the
secondary read we got that okay let's
move on to the next thing
listen move on to the next poster this
is by
excuse me hello I can't read it john
boule Johan Johan
yeah boule okay his house for Targaryen
have you seen this logo before I feel
like it's new you know I think we've
seen this one I think so yeah okay so
we've seen this and what do we think
about this Matthew wasn't working out my
technical issues here mm-hmm
hey I like the shapes in this poster I
can't quite make out everything in the
poster yet but I like that this is very
graphical well you have all these nice
shapes that are kind of coming out from
the center kind of highlighting the
sigil in the center I am guessing that
that's the head of a dragon in the
center and those are whole houses Lee
what do you think it is okay there's a
dragon in here somewhere
are we inside the mouth of a dragon
looking through at King's Landing as his
tongue is coming out you know what I'm
saying are we inside the mouth of Dragon
I see you see what I'm saying
mmm maybe I don't know I'm just throwing
it out there it's probably not I'm just
maybe giving the person more credit I
don't know but it's that would be pretty
cool though right because that's a very
unique perspective so let me see if I
can't help to make that clear if that
were the intent okay so quickly the word
mark is really nice I like it Targaryen
I just don't think that shield the
residual should be right smack dab in
the center it's like when we have an
element like this we don't know what to
do with it so we just Center everything
entire layout is symmetrical but I think
it'd be really cool if you had the
tongue here and this were the inside of
the mouth and then you can see the teeth
coming down oh my god keep coming up
that'd be sad and then you see a very
clear whatever King's Landing looks like
with the red key mm-hmm so instead of
that red keep it yeah we just don't know
what's gonna happen and then the
scorpions are like aimed right back at
it
oh yeah oh and you could do that thing
that they do and like movie posters like
a thousand arrows coming whoo right
that's like a blackout this guy with the
arrows blot out the sky that could be
kind of nice yeah people in the chat
saying that would be dope
don't open all right oh okay let's move
on yeah what else we got
this is no house Tyrell house Tyrell
Jonah who is that can you read that some
yes a little bit okay Alex Butler you
can read it I think that's what it says
okay so house Tyrell let's get back into
the house Tyrell okay so this is
interesting this is a story element I'm
gonna try to do this as delicately as
possible without spoiling this for
anybody but I guess if you're a hardcore
fan you you already kind of know what's
going on so it looks like they're
deciding who gets to become king so
there's a person and they're they're
kind of like waiting left and right this
person become king or this person become
king and it's kind of an important story
element so important that I wonder why
it's so small right so let's get back
into it what if this were this big right
like house Tyrell gets to decide and I
see this green shape what do you in this
green shape is Mathew is it just
textural I think it's just textural I
mean it could be the rose it could be a
rose but it's odd because it's green
yeah I do like it as an element so even
if you - even if it's just abstract if
it doesn't mean anything I kind of like
it well I'd like to give it meaning I'd
like to give it meaning if I can so what
if this were hands kind of coming
together like thinking about like
plotting mmm-hmm you know like when you
you have a deep thought and you plot mr.
Burnes hands mr. burns hands is that
what we're gonna call this not now mr.
burns there's an element in there and
you can make it a little abstract so it
becomes a secondary or tertiary read
tertiary spell T ier I think s CIA or
whatever tertiary but it's not like the
way you think it's spelled right House
Tyrell and then put the little emblem
let me do a light here put a little
emblem here and maybe the logo here
and then whatever copy you want here it
doesn't have to be centered not
everything has to be centered you guys
we can get away from that okay but
otherwise I think you have you're on to
something here I'd love to see a little
bit more of this and it's so small that
it can't read the type and I want to
talk about this when you're designing a
poster a movie poster or any kind of
poster you have to think I've got to
design this to be read from six feet
away so any kind of like a little bit of
type it's almost like legal copy the
executive producers or whatever that's
really not that important so if you want
somebody to read it you got to design it
to be few awards and much much bigger
because I can't read this I'm getting
old I'm losing my sight I can't see far
I can't see near so design for old
people and you'll be okay
mr. burns okay next one okay this is
from Boris score II scouts go Roy go run
Scout run yeah
ends with the end okay yes yes sky run
Boris go run okay this is for a house
Stark winter is coming the north never
forgets we see a Fang and a sword
through it which would seem to indicate
the killing of a beast which piece are
we killing is it's a wolf man you I
think they were just trying to combine
the two yeah but what kind of animal is
this this is not a white white don't
have things like this you think it's
supposed to be a direwolf things to
represent the stark house and then this
is the sword that was given to John yeah
but again I don't think that the sword
was from the house it is
representational of well it is it's iron
claw but iron claw was from the House
Stark no no it's not I think he was
given that sword wasn't he he was given
it in season one I believe
who gave it to him the commander of the
the Nights Watch the Lord Commander yeah
the Lord's gonna roast this right now to
one well we don't know our Game of
Thrones history but it's sword but
really it seems so violent against the
direwolf that it doesn't seem
right they work together right now
here's what I would do
here's my suggestion here first of all
get rid of the sword so I'm gonna try
and black it out real quick all right
just imagine that we're blacked out and
then I would darken all this stuff
because we don't want to see all that we
just want to see the fangs some of the
other designers who worked on the
project did a better job of learning how
to light and I think you should learn
how to light as well like darken some
parts we don't need to see all the light
doesn't need to go on pick a side pick a
direction like maybe it's lit from this
side and then everything else could be
dark you know what I would do is I would
put in you know the eyes of the wolf
maybe right so I'm not gonna be able to
draw wolf guys okay and then maybe you
can add the sword here like two swords
or something so at least we're working
together I don't know I just don't feel
great about stabbing through these
vampire dire wolf teeth he doesn't feel
quite right right if anything I would
had some crows in here maybe they're
often referred as crows from the
wildlings mm-hmm crow you know your crow
wife right your crow husband yeah okay
it's tricky I do like the teeth though
because that's pretty representational
but if you do have some a little bit of
that silhouette or the eyes in there
yeah I think that would be enough
something something in there okay let's
move on next up what's this by this is
by Ian Kelly okay who's this for Matthew
I don't know there's no house stated on
there there's no sigil there's no house
we see a scene the scene as well done
it's got nice atmospheric perspective
going yeah I think in the distance
there's a direwolf I think that's what
that is so I'm going to assume it's for
House Stark and I like the the
beginnings of this mm-hmm
and I think it would be much more
interesting it was House Stark winter is
coming and you saw the elements of a
white or then dead army in the back
right I think that would be pretty cool
and I think you could embrace this whole
unfortunately I don't have a lot of
shades of colors to work with but if
this were the white here and you could
see them a little bit mm-hmm emerging
from the mist mm-hmm and they're all
like broken and Jaggi like the undead
me that they are so that we know that
they've been warning about this thing
winter is coming and it's here yeah
that'd be pretty for something like that
and then we would just do stark right
and I do winter is coming
mm-hmm I think there's another element
that you guys can use if you want to
create a lot of depth Matthew's very
good at teaching this kind of stuff is
you change the scale so you have a
really big tree you have a medium tree
and you have really tiny little trees in
the background
and you're getting pretty good at that
right but if you were just to make some
of the trees bigger or add foliage in
the foreground that's much bigger scale
it would help to frame the shot a lot
better right so now we're looking in on
all this stuff right right
you could if you're really really good
and very clever with this stuff you
could use the black that you have for
the foreground to create another shape
because the way you're sketching this
right now it almost starts to feel like
the shape of a direwolf like the the you
know how it comes to a point there yeah
you know you could be very very clever
and very delicate in how you do that so
you might use the black there to create
some shapes that might resonate right
second or third read of a direwolf or
something okay you keep talking because
I'm gonna look up some reference here no
wolf head let's see what I got here wolf
head so I can sketch in that for you yes
good people know what I'm talking about
the other parts of this look really nice
because there's a lot of detail and this
one I think compared to some of the
other posters we looked at I liked that
all the branches there's so much detail
in there you have a good sense of
atmosphere going very far back it just
has a great mood it's just lacking a lot
of story and there there could be more
moments where you do get a little bit
more clever and have more fun with this
right
I found the reference so let's say that
there was something here and it started
to indicate the nose of the wolf mm-hmm
that's what you're talking about right
yes exactly and over here you see a
branch or something mm-hmm yeah oh
that's so cool all right guys it's
almost there it's like this is it here
there's an ear here you guys are
following me here people on the Internet
yeah I can I'm trying to be careful not
to draw too much of it right so that it
becomes like oh my god that's that's
what that is so I think there
is definite line here that you want to
straddle and you want to be careful
about indicating it versus like old dude
come on
retrieve like that right that could be
like some foliage a nest or something
and then that's the bottom of the nose
and the mouth of somewhere in here and
we really want to play up the fact that
these are the ears so I might fill in
this a little bit more mm-hmm so you can
see the ears a little bit better that's
super cool you know one campaign or
poster series that did this very well
was for the Batman series yep I think it
was the last one where you it was an
upshot where you're looking up at the
cityscape and it was made up of a bunch
of like either crumbling buildings or
building that yeah and then it created
an upright the bat the bat symbol there
so that was a really good example where
somebody had done this where they're
using this double reed in in the image
that was created and I found it let me
let me switch over my monitor here so
you guys didn't see what Matthews
talking about come on I don't want to
software update not now not in the
livestream Apple relax okay here we go
so here's the poster i zoom in a little
bit so you guys can see that
that's what Matthews talking about
there's buildings and in the negative
space you see the Batman logo there's a
lot of planning that has to happen so
that just reads correctly there's
another great poster it's called let me
type it in cabin in the woods poster I
think it's this one here is it
isn't in this movie I could have swore
it was this one with the trees in the
skull I know what you're talking about
but I don't I don't know what the name
of the movie woods movie poster come on
look like a doofus right now there it is
cabin fever sorry look at cabin fever
hmm you know right let me say that a
little bit better whoo that's cool
have you seen that one before Matthew
yes
kay Liam early was saying the Ali mosque
darth vader poster similar to that ideas
well yeah so that's why we made that
reference for you guys okay so cool so
cabin fever the trees make up a skull
and there's a cabin in there and some
people see you and some people don't
mm-hmm depends how dark your mind is and
my mind is pretty dark I suppose so I
see it right away okay let's move on
let's move on to the next one the next
one is from Michael Caleb subpart a
michael caleb is a party i assume this
is for House Stark but once again I I
don't know there's no I have to assume
right after you I don't like to assume
this person who's a silhouette of I
think that's John I see a little man bun
and some fur on the shoulders yeah looks
like his silhouette his profile uh-huh
his beard and mustache something there
mm-hmm and then it looks like the people
that are in the middle of the frame are
probably the Nights Watch or hit the
band of people that he travels with in
the later parts of the season series
who's the guy with the with the fire
sword
I think it's beric Dondarrion the Lord
of Light warriors you know so they're
out there there was a really cool moment
in the previous season season seven
right when they go out north of the wall
and they're gonna find they're on a
mission I don't want to say and it's
like a band of brothers a fellowship if
you will of the coolest people going out
and trying to find something out north
of the wall there you are so he has a
flaming sword but that's not really
John's role in there so I really don't
know what's going on or how it relates
to House Stark so
kuu element image within an image you
see that there's dragon flying up there
somewhere to man and it looks like there
oh I know what this is I know exactly
what this is this is the scene when the
White Walkers are descending on that
patch of ice
you see the whites in the foreground I
think that's what that is okay yeah I
think they're like coming in a horde of
zombies and there's just one moment and
they're all getting ready for their
final days on earth yes and then the
dragon in the distance is gonna maybe
come and help we don't know right so I
think there's a lot of storytelling
going on I just don't know if that's the
best representation for how stark I love
that scene myself so kudos to you for
that it's a really well illustrated
poster I think we need to refine the
concept in the moment and we're missing
some other elements right mm-hmm okay
very good job let's move on bill ooh des
I love is aisle Oh am I missing no
syllable here Jonah can read it Jonah
eagle-eyes no I I mean that's the best
pronunciation it's DZ IA l oh it could
be that the D in the Z or likes like
Xylo like well whatever bill you did a
good job here this is for house
targaryen mm simple mark you've got the
sigil integrated into the bottom of it
that's like one of the first
applications we've seen that because
people don't know what to do with the
sigil and I think that's good
integration you get the whole fire and
blood thing a house is firing blood you
have Danny walking in on the battlefield
looks like a lot of fallen soldiers
spears fire and then you see what I seem
to be drug on right it's nice a
symmetrical composition good use of
colors
you're not gonna overwhelm me with too
much information it says something it's
it's kind of complete yeah I love the
color use in this too because it has
these nice magentas and purples in there
and then that orange fiery red to go
with the fire and blood so there's a lot
of conceptual things a lot of stuff that
I think you had noted that it feels like
a complete well-thought-out idea and I'm
a sucker for this color palette too so
yeah lots of good depth going all the
way back you get some nice layers first
read with that dress
again ii read with danny they're in yeah
that's it's great i don't know what else
to really add to this
well sometimes i'm gonna try to mess it
up matthew i feel an obligation to try
to do something here when I look at the
silhouette of the Dragon III there's
creative interpretation and then there's
being faithful to the source material
I'm not sure how faithful this dragon is
but let's just say it is I feel like the
neck is really thick mmm right I feel
like this is the breast of the dress let
me switch ink here this is the breast of
the Dragon because I feel like I want to
cut this back a little bit so that
there's a little negative shape and I
could see a little the wing and I don't
mind that and then when you design the
dress and all that stuff how it
disappears into that so my eye wants to
fill in what the rest of this image
looks like so I'm really thinking about
silhouettes and shapes as a graphic
designer
mm-hmm and that's all I'm thinking about
okay but otherwise I think it's awesome
so I can imagine that the wing let's
just say this is the rest of it is there
and he's rearing back you know that's it
otherwise I think it's an excellent
poster yeah okay let's move on the next
one this is all same person it's going
for two for here yeah bills doubling up
his odds of winning something here so
this is not only from bill and it's a
really great illustration so bill you
must be an illustrator because this is
pretty dope
same logo same same situation is
phenomenal I think it's so detailed very
very nice I think the last poster for me
was more successful just because there's
more just more depth to it there's a lot
better contrast and I just I like that a
little bit better or this one I think
the illustration is good but in terms of
I guess what's here in the frame there's
not much you know there's not like the
second or third read in here that I
really enjoyed with the previous poster
and now that I'm looking at this I'm
wondering if at first I was wondering
like where did this circle come from and
what does it mean but I remember in one
of the episodes where you have the
dragon kind of
as a strategical moment the dragon kind
of flying in the Sun in the pathway of
the Sun careful careful
I'm just saying yeah I get it to block
the visibility maybe that's where that
that that's where that shape is coming
from uh-huh
okay so I have a couple things I want to
talk about here sometimes when your
design is close to being symmetrical I
just want it to be symmetrical and I'm
feeling that right now
I think it would be cool if you just
went a little wider so that we got to
see this part so an equal amount of
wingspan on both sides and reframed it
so that the posters gonna have to be a
little bit bigger so let's say it's out
here right a little bit taller so that
you can get this sucker to be dead
center mm-hmm okay and then the circle
lives wherever it lives and if it's
really a design element like the Sun I
would just make a little bit smaller so
he's coming out of the circle versus
maybe the scale feels a little bit off
to me and then I think we want to do
something a little bit more with the
typography feels like it's its only
purpose is to fill a technical
requirement right so there's I was
driving down Lincoln towards Abbot
Kinney in Venice and I saw these movie
posters from the new Godzilla movie and
there are four posters in total this one
from Mothra you see the symmetry and the
Mothra wings using dual tone like pallet
of turquoise teals and blues the
Godzilla and then you see the three
helicopters flying towards us gives us a
really good sense of the scale that
great use of atmospheric perspective
this is the series here so Rodin and
then how do you say that okay Dora
that's we headed dragged the
three-headed monster so this is really
cool as a campaign thanks yeah yeah oh
my gosh so nice right and then we have
the one with Godzilla who's a little bit
different everybody else because his is
not symmetrical mm-hmm because you know
why because the spine of Godzilla the
electricity lighting it up in the sky
mm-hmm and then I liked that they had an
element for contrast a little person in
the foreground or a jet so you really
understand the scale of everything right
so if we take a lesson out of that we
could put in something small here
so the
we understand what's going on mm-hmm
like the Dragons not that big but let's
just say it's like that right right and
then you can get a real sense like oh my
god something Bad's gonna happen right
and you can stack people in space so
design tip for you is put in some
element we recognize that we understand
scale mm-hmm there could be a boat here
this could be the sail like a boat sail
here and it's massive right and then you
see like oh my god it's coming right
like this is the bow of the boat I think
there was a poster like that to like
tear and standing on the bow of a boat
okay cool good job let's move on
Dexter wanted to point out that that's
the red comet red comet I think it was
in season 2 yeah season 2 yeah what is
the red comment it would appear didn't
the sky I think oh that's a historial
Ament that yeah the book fans know that
the TV fans didn't really get much yeah
okay fair enough okay let's move on this
is now Emory Duncan for House Stark this
is Ned Stark Eddard Stark right yeah I'm
guessing it's Ned Stark yeah and it
looks like there's a double reed here I
didn't see it at first but it looks like
there's small people there at his throat
he'll snap what do you I can't see it
from here woody what do you think that
is it looks like Joffrey the Queen and
somebody with an execution blade and
somebody kneeling to the ground oh so I
like these kinds of things but
unfortunately I mean that's a really
hidden element in there right that is
slightly unnatural to the scene itself
because it's not like hidden in the
shadows so the way that you do that is
you light this thing a little bit more
okay so you have sorry you have black on
here so the lighting direction is going
this way because that's the dark side
right so I think if you were to hide a
little bit more of this in the I don't
know something is not is it that the
face has got too much detail or it feels
like auto trace or something Matthew
help me out I think something is off
yeah I think the it looks like in the
throat there normally how it's been done
in some of the previous examples that
we've seen people have utilized the idea
of a silhouette or some kind of double
exposure the way that this one is
executed right now it's not using that
silhouette the kind of the dark areas of
character to create a second image on
the inside instead they Illustrated a
character on top of this and it's kind
of just put on top of the skin of this
characters things so the executions a
little funny and it's a little confused
I think in terms of I understand where
this is coming from but I don't think it
was executed as well as some of the
other ones that we've seen yeah I think
you're talking about using the natural
shadows in a scene mm-hmm and playing
off that for the cool double exposure
hidden thing versus a super imposition
right so I I don't know what this image
would be and we got to find something
where little shapes like this exists so
that it works but it's it feels a little
forced in the throat mm-hmm that's all
but maybe you're saying something about
like how honor duty and what you say
what you do something there oh I think
there is something conceptual because
the idea what Ned Stark always taught
everybody is that you carry out the
execution or what do you say you carry
out the like if you decide you carry out
the execution right yeah yeah so there
maybe there's something conceptual there
that's why there's a person kneeling
over yeah yeah yeah so that's Orion it's
a lot of story to tell that might be
giving away more than it's supposed to
right okay let's move on next up is
Wayne lacunae some really cool things
here a House Targaryen sigil logotype
I'm liking the word mark excuse me the
the image within the image so here's a
big silhouette there's a scene here and
armies getting destroyed or vanquished
by one of the dragons just look some
cool effects in it for some reason for
me personally Matthew the bright baby
blue the Tiffany blue is just really
sending me to a different place yeah and
I think it's just really that and it
could just be as critical as choosing
the right colors to compliment this
right right I mean technically blue is a
complementary hue to orange so I could
see why that person might
chosen it but I think because they're
both equally saturated or it feels
similarly saturated they're fighting
with each other where if you just pick
the very light tan or a white I think
that this one would be so killer but
that blue is just it's good you know
what it is I think it's the chroma like
the amount of saturation mm-hmm that
exists within the blue
it feels really artificial whereas you
have this kind of old almost like a
water color bleeding ink effect and
there's there's a much more nuanced
treatment to the image itself if you
just done this on a darker background
maybe a deep brown color or some other
color as long as it contrasts against
what is there and contrast could just be
value and doesn't have to be necessarily
you okay and if you don't know what
we're talking about if I'm using the
terms incorrectly just refer to Gregg's
video on understanding color theory the
basics the Regan here Gregory what do
you say you know he would tell us what's
up so Wayne lacunae I think a good idea
good composition I just think the colors
killing you on this mm-hmm I also wanted
to point out again I think there's some
nice conceptual plays here with the
tagline fire and blood it's nice to have
this bright orange on the inside to
represent the fire and then the water
color or just kind of like the spotted
liquid to represent the blood so I think
there was some very thoughtful elements
that were put in here that's why they
were chosen there so if only that color
was not this baby blue I think this
would be so excellent you know what I'm
realizing Matthew mm-hmm it's 122 and we
need to do the rest of this in eight
minutes so we can go eat all right all
right so we're not gonna spend as much
time talking about the work as we have I
hope you guys don't feel short shrift or
Kane shortchanged yeah that's a is the
expression that we do know so let's get
into it let's do this kind of quick are
one of our favorite people can tell you
sheet is back at it again excellent
illustration really strong force
perspective very graphic super-powerful
John snow is standing there and we know
it's John snow because it says John snow
up the front the true air I think we're
giving a little bit too much information
away there I would just prefer John snow
Game of Thrones or House Stark and then
there's something about dragon
coiled underneath on his feet beautiful
composition maybe it needs to be cropped
tighter crop tighter mm-hmm and then do
something with Stark right John snow and
don't give up don't give away anything
okay let's keep moving
Matthew why don't you take this one
there's one beautiful colors sucker for
these this color palette
I think it's lacking a little bit of
contrast it's hard to read the
silhouette in the middle of the frame I
wish that popped out a little bit more
so a little bit of the popping and
contrast I think the silhouette of the
three dragons we don't necessarily need
three dragons even if you just had the
one with wings could also be very
interesting to look at and unfortunately
this one is missing the sigil and the
ward mark but I think a really good
effort some very nice details it just
needs to pop more and could be
simplified in the silhouette yeah for me
it's the resolution of the three dragons
it feels really strange like it's
somewhere between cut out and
Illustrated so it's like the neck is a
little thin here and just there's weird
details here that are just a little odd
for me so just work on the silhouette
itself and refine it a little bit I
think it's somebody in the probe and
mention this but nothing changed so mm
whatever gone okay this is from well we
didn't say who this was from this is
from soon a quest soon a quest okay and
then this one is up from Calum eerily oh
I like this a lot
yeah that's someone's damn very nice
this I think has a great sense of really
big object medium sized object and
really tiny detail so it has a very nice
dynamic feel to it you get the cool
silhouette of it's interesting you could
still read it as Danny even though it's
front-facing typically when you do these
silhouettes you don't want to do it
front-facing because there's not enough
significant details on a person usually
you do a profile or 3/4 because this is
much easier to read on a person but for
whatever reason this works I kind of
know that this is her and I love the
nice little placement of the pine throne
right at the center there at the base of
the red Keith and then the dragons
flying in the sky I mean this thing is
beautiful it's a really good poster I
think some of this is little comfortable
for me I think we need to go a little
wider on it so that it doesn't see these
little edges here yeah we got to watch
out for that stuff otherwise I'm really
enjoying this I would refer the the
house here Megerian something I don't
know if we need season eight and all
minimum styles I stuff I really like to
thrown the backdrop to three dragons
even though it might not exactly line up
with a story that's totally okay
understand okay because it's really
about the quest who's gonna win the
throne okay next up a little
send up here calling out this is almost
like a meme poster right as you saw this
might do really well on the Internet
in terms of making fun of the series so
the Starbucks controversy targaryen I
don't want to spend too much time
talking about this I think this is
pretty funny yeah I think is a little
different than what we were looking for
personally I'm gonna just get real
technical with you here I want to talk
about the steam so I think when you
design steam you have to kind of pay
close attention to where the shape works
it should get thick and thin and it
swells here let me undo all that so you
guys can see what I'm doing this part
the shape here it feels a little funny I
think a little refinement on that could
work okay
I think you missed an opportunity here
Targaryen right here man why not maybe
we don't need this zoom in to a little
bit better yeah yeah that would have
been perfect just bring the outlets
together yeah that would have been
perfect that's it okay let's keep moving
good job Ryan funny guy sylveon says
it's not Starbucks its Targaryen star
guarantee star garyun okay this is by
Jarek Karpin Jarek arpan okay house
Greyjoy some really cool things
happening here and then there's some
things we got to work out okay you see
when you have such an expressive word
mark like this it's hard to design
around so this is a lesson for all you
guys who design word marks that you just
need to keep in mind that there's the
whole context and applications you have
to design
or when it's so integrated in so many
elements so many story bits to it a
fights against everything else but let
me talk about what's good about this so
what's good about this is that you see
the Greyjoy like the baddest pirate that
ever sailed the seas and then there's
this double image here and it looks like
the Kraken right so that's like a giant
squid and I think that's really cool
otherwise the composition is a little
flat for me I think having other
elements in here to show scale could
help me undo all that junk
sorry guys hang in there see because
there's just this one horizon line and
then there's just one medium and then
one small what if you had something much
bigger in the foreground it could be
that this is the bottom of another boat
I don't know what happens with the
composition or it's sailing into a
harbor something else needs to happen
here maybe a little bit more lighting so
that's not the values don't separate
it's like dark on top of dark and then
Greyjoy maybe that's white and much
smaller a little element here you can
add the stars hmm dad a little pop to it
mm-hmm okay or you can add a little bit
of fire on these other boats like if you
watch a series oh my gosh when you see
that ship coming you run right you just
run you just I would just jump off the
boat alright you're done and you can
integrate your word mark potentially and
and your sigil on to the masthead here
or the masts mm-hmm that would be kind
of cool okay and and maybe you move the
logo down here nice yeah that's it let's
move on okay Viktor Leo Viktor Leo the
North remembers there's the gods tree
the bleeding eyes the the tree itself
and then it's integrated with a wolf's
thoughts Matthew I like the idea
oh yeah using these things together but
I feel like the integration of the tree
going into the wolf just doesn't it
doesn't feel like they're well put
together but I love the idea of it just
using that negative space that's created
by the the red leaves of the tree so
I think what might have been more
interesting is what we were exploring
earlier where we're trying to create
that direwolf shape out of the forest
yeah if we could have used this just
have the red tree fill up the top of the
frame and then we could use to use
branches to help illustrate the details
of the direwolf in there yeah honestly I
think the direwolf is really not that
important of a character element here it
really isn't so I think if you just made
this all red it would probably be a lot
more powerful we don't need the wolf at
all
mm-hmm and then we have to fight to see
the tree then something else could
happen in the top part of this frame or
the bottom parts I don't know mm-hmm and
it could be very very beautiful red and
white oak on a stock background could be
super powerful I think we need to spend
a little bit more time illustrating the
tree itself because it looks a little
click party looks a little like line
drawing so work on that and I think you
could have something really hot okay
let's move on
wean lacunae another one right that's
multiple entries from Wayne where where
else is Wayne
I saw Wayne's name before no I think so
okay anyways another poster for the
Targaryen fire and blood we have the ice
the Ice King I believe in the bottom
right corner we had the three dragons
Danny's head and rainy and then little
kind of bits of snow in there for one
thing just I'm reading this purely on an
aesthetic level I feels a little too
digital to vector clip arty and I think
we need to spend a little bit more time
working on the forms and and how they're
lit things don't feel as integrated it
feels like elements placed on top of
elements for me Matthew your take yeah I
mean yeah I agree with you I think if
the I think the intention was the
Dragons to feel more like the braids in
her hair it doesn't feel like it's
reading very well it doesn't feel like
it's decided one way or the other
what I do like about this is that the
knight The Dark Knight is kind of
filling her silhouette and there's
something quite nice about the
juxtaposition of those two but I feel
like it's so many story elements that
are fighting against each other to try
and tell us something here and I don't
know what that is yeah and it doesn't
seem like the the knight King is like
her battle to fight she's the battle for
the throne right and this is like oh no
it's battle to fight and so if you're
gonna pick an element I think King's
Landing the throne the Iron Throne
something like that might make more
sense okay and last last little warning
here is like when you use a really
bright saturated orange and really
bright saturated blue it's screaming at
you I would push the chroma back down a
little bit some some of the saturation
is just too heavy okay mm-hmm all right
another poster for the Targaryen house
this is from Jason Tucker mm-hmm I think
this is one of our favorite marks for
Targaryen mark simple sigil and it looks
like that's Tyrion no I think that's
supposed to be Danny and that's a
generate yeah I thought it was Tyrion at
first because of the proportions yeah
but I think that's Danny and that's the
end of our hair coming off that's not oh
I see and then in the wake of the the
battle there it's a burnt burnt City
with the dragon flying away I see the
walls broken there I see it yeah okay I
get it now so we have some confusion as
to what the silhouette is just be
mindful that you pick a really powerful
easily recognized silhouette so that the
story elements are super clear mm-hmm
okay I did I know also feel like this
one is also very digital looking it
feels a little bit like auto trace
vector clip art so be mindful of that
okay mmm all right next up Kyla daily
this is a freshly made poster because
this is straight out of the last last
episode yeah episode 6 of season 8 and
Danny singing top of the stairs with the
unsullied and her devil like wings
spreading in the background I won't say
what what that all means it feels a
little vector a little kind of just kind
of missing a little bit of that pop that
cinematic quality to it it feels very
very flat mm-hmm and there's a couple
things that you can do to change that
and I'm going to show you right now
Matthew anything you want to say no okay
I think compositionally while you're
drawing that like I think
compositionally it's interesting I like
that the weight is at the bottom and you
have this expansive skyline in the
background that's way in the back that
you can read as you go up to Targaryen
but I feel like
it's it's it's just lacking a lot of
details and some nice color and in
contrast so what I'm doing here is I'm
just showing you how to do the stairway
and so if you show the stairway even
though the same perspective same angle
if you show an element like that's a
person and then you show more people in
the foreground that are bigger and
bigger and bigger then it shows you that
there's depth that's going back into
space and you can have the arch and then
you can have Danny standing there with
the wings just like the way you have it
and you're not inherently changing the
design I'm trying not to change the
design too much right okay so you can
create depth that way and it's a really
important for you guys to be able to do
that right and by doing things like this
it starts creating leading line swords
it's moving your eyes so your eye is
following now the repetition of objects
pointing you directly to the center
which is Danny and then your eye will
naturally go up to read the rest of the
frame so you can control things like
this as a designer as an illustrator the
way you compose frame dictates how
somebody's eye moves across the frame
[Music]
yep somebody's been watching a little
bit of what's that channel with Ted soon
Oh Indy mogul Indy mogul leading lines
okay next up this is from Kento Yoshida
again the prolific Kento Yoshida let it
be fear that's a that's a nod to a line
that is said in the last season there's
there's some issues of this I love the
dragon the face and I love the red teeth
this is a great way to like really just
draw some detail so that your eye just
doesn't disappear into the into the void
the Oblivion right it's missing the
sigil it could use another story element
and let it be fear is way too big if you
just made a lot smaller it would it
would work maybe on one line let it be
fear mm-hmm there's some typography
things so Kento is obviously a good
illustrator maybe still need to work on
your typography skills there's too much
lighting between the line let it be fear
and we need something else in here okay
otherwise a nice composition when you
have a beautiful illustration to work
with it's it's a lot nicer to start your
design process that way mm-hmm okay
targaryen this is from an ass better cut
you I can't totally tell what's going on
here it looks like three-headed dragon
it looks like a fireball and a web or
maybe the wings of the dragon
it feels very Asian to me which isn't
necessary good nor bad but it's just I I
think I'm gonna just make one quick
addition here I think if you can make
the wings a little bit more pronounced I
would just make all of this red I don't
think this teardrop fireball shape is
really adding much I don't know what it
is yeah okay like look look at how much
more powerful - Stella what's gonna pop
now right oh yeah much better okay so
what I would do is make the wings a lot
bigger so imagine that they were there
mm-hmm that could look pretty scary yeah
right and then you can move the type of
up top or whatever else is the story
element that you want to say so it would
need one more element in here to kind of
complete a narrative thing mm-hmm but at
least then it would be very graphic
right and you're not just doing graphic
on graphic because I think that was the
problem here that this person probably
got too clever it's like I'm gonna add
fire man it had this dragon I'm gonna
superimpose them on top of each other
it's just hard to read yep whereas if
you had just a big element some medium
elements and some tiny elements it would
be a lot better so that your eye can
kind of make a distinction between the
two okay ooh Kendra will Williford I
think that's it yeah
Kendra will afford there's a lot of
lines in that name yeah okay house
Bolton our blades are sharp this is a
pretty cool poster I have to say the
flayed man with the edges with the
blades all over it's kind of an
interesting way to integrate that I just
like having one strong element like this
maybe the house Bolton could be shrunken
down a little bit it's a little bit big
for me I don't love that kind of Celtic
lettering style but that's not the
challenge the challenge was to design a
poster with the word mark do design in
the digital I think this is quite nice
and he went add to that yeah no I just
like that instead of the bones there you
have the knife so I thought that was a
really nice play on what you would
commonly see there and that illustration
details very
nice ho I do like this one nice okay
house Tyrell from Agni and Agnieska can
I'm not even try the last name Agnieska
nice job it seems like you you really
took to heart the whole landscape thing
with the one person in the in the
background or in the foreground I'm
sorry house Tyrell
this is where they they provide the food
for the Kingdom the Seven Kingdoms right
not a lot of dramatic questions being
asked here mmm-hmm beautiful depth in
here and I like that this is one of the
few that made a really big expansive
landscape based off of the references
that you showed yeah so I like the depth
that you have the the grass in the
extreme foreground and the med ground
you have this character and then the
castle in the back so I think it's a
great use of contrast and color but it
you're right it doesn't I don't know if
it adds anymore like outside of that
it's just a portrait of a scene yep okay
let's keep going here just brown this is
for house Tully one of my favorite
assiduous just super simple the fish
kind of abstracted I don't know what the
two rings are in the drop of blood I'm
pretty sure the fans of the show will
tell us in a second what it means from a
pure graphic point of view I like it I
just don't know what it means it is
almost like too reductive for me
anything Matthew yeah I just don't know
what to make of this I wish I could read
more into this or had some context so
maybe the internet will tell us how
Stolley what's going on Game of Thrones
this is Adam Harris again we don't know
what house this is for if you look
really closely this is a silhouette with
a wolf in the hairline there it almost
looks like Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart or
something it just it's a little bit off
for me it's hard to read who that is
it's a little hard to read and and this
is one of those things where you're
trying to get a double image in there
and you force it in because that shape
isn't I just don't feel like the shape
is part of that person's face I mean it
looks like you've added in there we're
missing how stark
I would just work on the illustration a
little bit more so that it's clear who
this is mm-hmm okay this is from Newton
and Newton's Ward mark here was one of
my favs did it win this one
it-it-it me one the wordmark you did win
the word mark yeah yeah the word mark
yeah not for the sigil and I think this
is just a word mark and the sigil put
together again with the sword maybe in
there I think right so the man who
passes the sentence should swing the
sword that's what you're talking about I
don't think it's adding a whole lot for
me personally right okay
let's move on they're trying to pick
this up sure off the North remembers
Game of Thrones missing how stark
illustration could use a lot of
refinement a little looks a little too
cartoony for me a little too simplistic
and reductive I think you're gonna do
the strong silhouette you need to make
sure that that reads like a really
powerful direwolf it looks a little like
a fox to me yeah anything else
no okay ooh Ian Kelly okay winter has
come so that looks like a knight a white
Walker isn't it mm-hmm looks like from
season one yeah beautiful lighting so
we've seen trees and forests and
lighting people who do this know how to
light this is a great use of composition
big things small things and the lighting
and the atmospheric perspective that's
really cool how stark is there another
story element I don't know but actually
is really well done I like the drawing
quite a lot mm-hmm
who did this one I don't know no name
they didn't use no name tablet oh my
gosh okay there's some really cool
things happening in here this is a
silhouette of the night King and the
eyes and the tree line up really nicely
yeah that's what Matthew's talking about
finding those nice alignments where it's
naturally exist and then emerging from
that forest towards the wall that's
pretty cool
we're missing a whole bunch of things
this isn't for a house white right so
what are we doing here I don't know okay
Adam Harris this must be for the great
joys and the Greyjoy's yeah it's a
little bit hard to read it's quite
abstract I think there's a boat in there
but much else I cannot figure out I'm
trying my hardest here and if I try too
hard it means it's not clear okay so
work on that I do like to call
I like how expressive it is but I can't
tell what it is mm-hmm
okay it's time for us Matthew who tops
Nick our top five top five was pretty
difficult to choose actually there was a
lot of great entries and there was a
good amount of you a third of you who
didn't fully follow the rules so we have
to weigh out three things right yeah the
concept the composition and then the
integration of the sigil and ward mark
okay so that's how we rated these ones
okay so in no particular order we're
going to show you who our top five are
for the third and final challenge the
poster design challenge for the game of
thrones unofficial challenge here here's
the first one I love that one oh okay so
this is from bill bill great job
beautiful job okay and to no surprise
bills back in it again oh my gosh
okay another great poster oh look at
that Jonah's saying he likes that yeah
it's a really nice poster huh well
there's really beautiful illustration we
can see that you're you're flexing your
illustration muscles that we like it
good job and then after that is Kendra
with house Bolton we really like this
composition very beautiful graphic
there's an unusual take on the house
Bolton flayed man the swords integrated
in there instead of the main arteries or
the bones as Matthew had pointed out
second to last is Lillian Figueroa
with her house Baratheon the stag what's
his name Robert Baratheon kind of just
waging war with his hammer or his axe or
something probably hammer and I'd double
image good colors good composition
beautiful job and last but not least is
Callum with the the iron throne the red
keep the Dragons and Danny in the
foreground really missing that the the
word mark and the sigil but other than
that really great design good job okay
that's it for us you guys Matthew tell
them what do they need to do they need
to vote up who their top choice is for
the poster design challenge correct will
tell you what the points are and then we
will sum it up and announce the winner
and send you your prizes so on behalf of
Matthew Jonah myself and our hungry
growling stomachs thank you and farewell
Game of Thrones it's not it didn't end
the way I hoped for
it didn't pay off in the way I hope for
but that's the name
the game that's the story of play you
don't get what you want see you guys
next time adios Matthew get us out of
here with some music
I think this died on me hello